En este video hablaremos del concepto de razón
y proporción entre magnitudes. El concepto de
proporcionalidad puede ser muy útil en muchas
situaciones de la vida real. Por ejemplo,
si pensamos en un grupo de hombres y mujeres
reunidos, podríamos encontrar la relación que hay
entre el número de mujeres respecto al de hombres.
Imaginemos que hay 10 personas en una oficina,
de las cuales cinco son mujeres y cinco son
hombres. Diríamos que la razón es que por
cada 5 mujeres hay 5 hombres. El concepto de
razón en matemáticas nos indica la relación
que existe entre dos magnitudes, por ejemplo,
puede ser una relación entre personas, objetos,
cantidades o situaciones como la descrita. ¿Te das
cuenta de que lo hemos expresado como una división
o como un cociente? La razón se define como la
relación entre dos cantidades y se puede expresar
como una fracción, y se lee: a/b, o bien a : b. En
nuestro ejemplo de la oficina, si simplificamos el
cociente 5/5 obtenemos 1/1, 5 es igual a 1
por 5, el 5 multiplica y divide, así que lo
cancelamos y tenemos 1 / 1. Por lo que podemos
decir que, en este ejemplo: por cada mujer en la
oficina hay un hombre. Esto que acabamos de hacer
es una proporción. La proporcionalidad es una
igualdad de razones, es decir, es una razón que se
expresa de maneras diferentes pero equivalentes.
Veamos más ejemplos. Vamos a pensar ahora que
estás leyendo un libro: si lees 15 páginas en 30
minutos tenemos esta razón; si continúas leyendo
al mismo ritmo, a esa misma razón, podremos saber
cuántas páginas leerás en una hora. Para obtener
la proporción, multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador de esta razón por 2: obtendremos
que leerás 30 páginas en una hora o 60 minutos.
Podemos encontrar otros ejemplos de relaciones
proporcionales en matemáticas. Observemos en
este ejemplo de sectores circulares la variación
proporcional de las áreas de acuerdo a la longitud
del radio que las determina. Aquí las longitudes
de los radios son múltiplos de un radio R.
Veamos otro ejemplo. ¿Recuerdas los triángulos
del teorema de Tales? La parte que nos dice:
si en un triángulo se traza una línea paralela a
cualquiera de sus lados se obtiene un triángulo
que es semejante al triángulo dado. Este
teorema puede usarse como un ejemplo más
de proporcionalidad. La semejanza entre estos
triángulos implica la existencia de una relación
de proporcionalidad entre sus lados; sin embargo,
también es muy frecuente encontrar magnitudes
que no son proporcionales, por ejemplo, la
longitud del lado de un cuadrado y su área,
la edad y la altura de niños o la distancia de
frenado y la velocidad de un vehículo. Ahora se
nos presenta este problema. Si con 126 dólares se
pueden comprar 6 pantalones, ¿cuánto se pagará por
la compra de 9 pantalones? ¿Cómo podemos resolver
este problema? Parece que el total a pagar por la
compra de pantalones depende de la cantidad que
se compre y, en efecto, se trata de un problema
de proporcionalidad. Un método muy útil para
resolver este problema es primero encontrar el
valor de un pantalón, de una unidad, para después
poder calcular el monto total a pagar por todos
los que deseamos comprar. A esto lo conocemos como
método de reducción a la unidad. El costo de cada
pantalón se obtiene dividiendo el monto total,
126 dólares entre el número de pantalones, 6. Otra
forma de decirlo es que hay una razón entre el
costo de los pantalones y el número de pantalones,
entonces: 126 / 6 = 21 dólares; entonces 126 / 6
= 21 dólares por pantalón. Ahora tengo el valor
de la unidad, o el costo por pantalón, y para
obtener la respuesta al problema voy a multiplicar
este valor por el nuevo número de pantalones que
quiero comprar, que en este caso es 9, y esto es
igual a 189. El total a pagar por 9 pantalones
es 189 dólares. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.